c'est à l'occasion de la sortie en dvd
blu ray de la planète des singes les
origines que nous avons eu la chance de
nous rendre en nouvelle zélande plus
particulièrement à wellington dans les
studios de weta digital pour en savoir
un peu plus sur ce film un peu
particulier
en effet à l'instar de tintin et
d'avatar la planète des singes a utilisé
la technique de la performance capture
pour donner vie à des personnages
numériques criante vérité
pour en savoir un peu plus nous avons eu
l'occasion de rencontrer joe letteri
superviseur des effets visuels du film
et le comédien andy serkis qui nous ont
donné un point de vue avisé sur la
performance capture
c'est ce que j'aime dans la performance
capture pouvoir jouer des personnages
très différents des personnages
extraordinaires tout en gardant
l'anonymat ça me va très bien
avec andy serkis on commence en général
par parler du personnage et du rôle et
de la façon dont il va essayer de
représenter en prenant en compte à la
fois l'évolution du personnage et sa
réalité physique quand on travaille
ensemble andy joue toujours des
personnages inexistant ou éloignés des
humains donc on en parle beaucoup on
utilise la motion capture très
rapidement pour avoir une représentation
du personnage qui lui servent de base de
travail on regarde ce qu'il a fait ce
qu'on a enregistrés et ont créé le
personnage numérique en étant très
attentif pour essayer de comprendre si
on a saisi ce qu'andy a cherché à
transmettre
c'est l'idéal pour un acteur à plusieurs
égards c'est son plus grand atout je ne
le connais pas très bien c'est parce
qu'il a d'autres à proposer donc c'est
plutôt positif pour l'arago
sète a créé un personnage numérique
autant qu'il s'agisse d'un personnage
non humains un personnage dans lequel on
reconnaît l'aspect humain et dont les
traits non humains éveillent l'attention
hussein
un
tournant intéressant cette année en
particulier car la planète des singes et
les amateurs de tintin illustre deux
usages différente de la performance
capture les performances émanent toutes
deux de jeu d'acteur leur transposition
à l'écran est différente maintenant que
la technologie a réussi à rendre les
choses plus transparentes à transposer
le jeu des acteurs avec justesse dans la
peau des créatures on entre dans une ère
intéressante
cette rc celle du tournage numérique à
ce propos notre journaliste yann
rutledge a eu le privilège de se mettre
dans la peau d'andy serkis pour
s'essayer à un tournage en performance
capture il a ainsi enfiler une
combinaison un peu spéciale pour refaire
plusieurs scènes du film vous allez voir
ce n'est pas de tout repos